看看这个毛衣好看
好看里边配个打底
或者你直接这样单穿
胸尾的话是120
胸尾120
长度的话36
来这一款谁要谁来扣29
29扣个2
29啊
谁要谁来扣个2
那个应该还能找得到
你要的话我给你找
我现在有藏青和米色
就是没有绿的
来这个外套来给网民看一下
粉色的
粉色的威领威领这个外套啊
有扣子的
它的扣子全部都是隐形的一个扣子啊
隐形的没有标了
你看里边的做工多好
全包边
看看连个线头都没有
越这样的我跟你说越
真的都是高货
来这一款粉色
粉色的这个威领威领这个风衣
两边有直插口袋
两边有直插直插口袋啊
来这一款咱们来量一下
胸尾胸尾
胸尾108110
108可以拉伸的110
群长108
来这个一长108
这个风衣啊外套
来这一款谁要谁来扣39
39扣个6
秒杀进你们了
谁要谁来扣39
39扣6扣6
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
来哎呀
外衣的这个裙子藏青色的这个又出来一条啊
又出来一条这一款吊摆架是9000多将近1万的原来59的啊
来这个腰上去带松紧腰腰上面是带松紧的非常非常好穿哦
这个是蕾蕾丝镂空的这种来胸尾的话是96102腰尾的话是六十八九十六十八九十群长的话是115来这个群的谁要191919谁要谁来扣个51919啊喜欢的姐姐没扣到的小姐姐可以来扣这个款划算的很哦
自己穿送人都可以
面料是真的好
在外面买的话有两三百一条肯定要的来这个摸C全棉的摸C全棉小鹿相间小鹿相间来给帮我们看一下这个全棉全棉前面有僵硬字母的棉一百棉一百啊来这款摸C摸C的胸围100106100106长度65啊
一长65来这款谁要9块9块扣5扣5啊
来喜欢的姐姐一口
9块9块扣5扣5啊
5块9块谁要谁来勾勾5全棉全棉
全棉全棉哦
9块勾勾9块勾勾5
来这个小短裙
白色的
白色的小短裙
牌子是这个牌
牌子是这个牌子的
来看一下
均码均码面料锯纸
面料锯纸的啊
腰是松紧腰腰是松紧腰
来小短裙白色
清爽腰围64
可以拉到96
同位的话不用量
长度的话45
来这款谁要9块9块扣8
9元9元谁要谁来扣个8
来喜欢的姐姐一口9块扣8
9块9块扣8
9块扣8
走过路过了不要错过了
哇这个衣服
超级舒服
来这个咖色的假两件
牌子这个牌子
面料应该是人棉加锯纸
人棉加锯纸的
M码
人棉36
人棉35锯纸65
假两件
咖色咖色的这个假两件
这个小裙子啊
身体非常好看
超软超软的
胸围的话是98106
腰围的话62可以拉到84
62 84来裙长的话是109
来这个啊
上身超级好看
来谁要29
29扣0
咖色的假两件
看腰是带松紧的啊
腰是带松紧的
里边是个背心
他外面加了一个带袖子的
来夹两件
夹两件啊
29 29谁要谁来扣个二
单层没有里层
面料超软
超软超软的面料
哇塞这个是啥裤啊
太舒服了
这个面料
免一板
看看脚口带松紧
腰上松紧腰
腰上有出绳
两边有鞋衫都单层单层啊
免一板
免一板免一板啊
来这个米色的这个裤腰围呃60可以拉到90啊
腿围106可以拉伸到112106112
当长是35裤长的话是93
来
这种裤子谁要谁来扣3939扣个六39扣个六全年一百的全年一百的脚口带松紧啊
脚口带松紧的姐妹们看一下
休闲了休闲了
这个全年全年3939喜欢的姐姐一扣了3939
其实就是这个肌肉的这一 treadmill
买牌100并die
这של送了拼封都二十一 exceptional
里面这个抙子
count
扭分
反之
这个 attitude
当 Jah
来这么像马甲
面料锯子的 coriander
面料锯子
s u r 他们家的面料锯子
г
来这一款谁要二十九二十九
扣个一
二十九二十九
谁要谁来扣个一
来喜欢的姐姐一波二十九扣一
来这个透极山
有扣有扣呀的
来这一款透极山
可以防晒可以外搭
里边有弧度的
里边有弧度
但是前面这里我看有一个
有一条这个
应该是脏的
但是我不确定能不能洗掉
看到了吗
那所以这个就给大家放福利
九块九块九块
胸围120
长度来前面是七十四
后面是八十
来九块九块
扣一扣一
来喜欢的姐姐一波九块九块
谁要谁来扣个一
谁来扣个一
来喜欢的姐姐一波九块九块
扣一扣一
来这个圆领圆领
圆领圆领
面料锯纸的
我知道我知道
写着你的名字了
来这一款
圆领圆领
这个蓝蓝
黑底这个紫花的
来圆领面料锯纸
面料锯纸的
底下
那下摆打个结
下摆可以打个结
来这一款咱们来量一下
胸围胸围
来长度
前面57
后面62
来这一款谁要谁来扣九块九块
扣二扣二
来喜欢的姐姐一波九元九元
谁要谁来扣个二
九块九块扣二扣二
来喜欢的姐姐一波九元九元谁要谁来扣个二
这个小外搭
腰剪掉了
是一个小外搭米色的
它前面就是这样不规则的
miso前面就是这样不规则的
来直筒袖
看一下后面
看一下后背这样子的
来这个外搭我来量一下
你们要的话也给你们放福利
来胸围胸围
九合
来这一款
出亲戚这个
中间
94 96 94 96
来长度的话是46
来这款谁要9块9块
扣1扣1啊
9块扣1来这个外搭
非常好看的米色前面是不规则的啊
来谁要谁来给我9块
摸着应该是含棉挺高的
含棉量挺高的
9块9块
喜欢的姐姐就给我9块9块扣1扣1啊
来一个来一个
哎呦我怎么扔那么准啊
我怎么扔的那么准啊
来这个格子的小小吊带裙
但是他有袖子啊
有袖子的知道了吗
咱这个带子你自己系
你可以系短一点
可以系长一点
后面有隐形拉链的
来这里是有弹力的有松紧的啊
腰上面看有两根带子
两边都可以打蝴蝶结
来这个小格子看看
这个小格子黑白格
黑白小格子的这款
来瘦的小姐姐
瘦小的小姐姐
穿好看胸尾的话是88
88之前有好多姐姐要这个款找不到
腰尾的话6668
裙长的话是93
来这个裙子谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣
来1919扣3扣3
喜欢的姐姐就扣了啊
小格子的黑白格的这个小裙子
来谁要谁来扣
谁要谁来扣
喜欢的姐姐就扣哦
来半身裙来喽
半身裙来了啊
苹果气泡在不
来这个裙子
这个是小马s的
人眠36巨指64
这个裙子就是你昨天晚上有抠
抠一条还是两条忘了
但是这个是另外一个颜色
腰围的话66
腿尾的话是104108
裙长的话是59
这个裙子9块9块
扣0扣0
9块扣0哎呦这个有点
这个有一点点瑕疵
你等一下抠别的
你等一下抠别的这个送你
这个有瑕疵
这个天能穿能穿
就有一点点
起泡了那你就说想想破还没破
来扣别的送你
我扣别的我送你
刚那个衬衣裙
那个衬衣裙要要春秋穿
啊那个是全面那个长袖你看看
那个要春秋天穿
啊现在不能穿有点热
来这一款来给帮我们看一下藏青色的
藏青色的这个裙
啊来看一下这个是
面料锯纸的啊西装面料面料锯纸
面料锯纸
这是一个15码
15码15码左边有隐形拉链的来
腰围72 74 72 74
横围124128
裙长56
来这个裙子9块9块扣6
9块扣个6到膝盖啊
这种裙子穿出来显得人高显得人瘦
因为他是像这种打褶的看有几片
谁要谁来扣9块9块扣个6
近距离给你们看一下
非常好看哦
这个是咱没有烫
你回家洗一下
烫一下更好效果更好啊
9块9块扣6扣6
洗完了姐姐就给我9块9块
扣个6扣个6
来这个小裙子啊
也是西装面料啊
后面有隐形拉链的
来这个后面底边开个叉
后面底边开个小叉啊
腰围76 78
臀围96 98
裙长48
来这个谁要9块扣1
9块9块谁要谁来扣个1
9块扣19块扣1
谁要谁来扣9块扣个1
9块扣1
9块扣19块扣1
来这个
泡泡裙
灯笼裙